[Musique]
un million de cyclotouristes en 2017
la loire à vélo séduit de plus en plus
notamment grâce à l'amélioration des
services proposés ils nous fournissent
les vélos les cartes les équipements
même nos bagages sont transférés d'un
hôtel à l'autre pendant que nous roulons
entre deux étapes
c'est vraiment super
600 professionnels du tourisme sont
labellisés loire à vélo une marque
convoité qui garantit une augmentation
de la fréquentation
m
notre chiffre d'affaires a été multiplié
par 8 avec la loire à vélo
donc effectivement pour nous c'est très
important que c'est une clientèle très
agréable les deux régions et les
collectivités locales ont investi 50 7
millions d'euros dans cette véloroute
unique en france
treize ans après l'inauguration du
premier tronçon le placement s'avère
très rentable
les touristes à vélo consomment ils
consomment en moyenne 80 euros par jour
plus que les touristes qui utilisent la
voiture etc
les retombées économiques sont
colossales 30 millions d'euros l'année
dernière
la loire à vélo est devenu un véritable
levier pour l'aménagement du territoire
brémond petit village aux airs de bout
du monde entre tours et summer dominique
raclant ya posé ses valises après des
années à l'étranger pourrait ouvrir un
cycle au café il répare l'on vend des
pièces détachées effets de la petite
restauration
il y a deux ans je suis arrivé de
londres
en france il y à 2 150 cyclos café dans
le centre mais il n'y en a qu'un au bord
de l'eau et le concept marche bien une
cinquantaine de cyclotouristes s'arrête
ici chaque jour
ukr which has est un get back to
villandry en ce début de saison les
touristes étrangers sont moins nombreux
que l'année dernière comme ils
représentent 70 % de sa clientèle
dominique les soigner ils ont un fort
pouvoir d'achat
quand il parcourt la loire à vélo ils
dépensent davantage que les français
notre budget 20 est d'environ 150 euros
par jour
même chose pour manger notre budget
quotidien est d'environ 500 euros
évidemment dominique n'a pas des clients
comme ces américains tous les jours son
commerce ne fonctionne que six mois par
an et dépend de la météo
pourtant ça marche et c'est tout le
village qui en profite
nous sommes trois commerce vous avez une
boulangerie vous avez petit hôtel
restaurant bar tabac et moi et bien sûr
il ya eu un boum à partir de 2016 sur le
fait qu' on est en trois ans se
partageant on va dire certains services
bien différent sans se faire concurrence
ça bien sûr booster nos chiffres
d'affaires bien sûr
[Musique]
que serait le petit village de bray et
mon sens ses activités autour du
cyclotourisme certainement une carte
postale de bord de loire
[Musique]
à quelques coups de pédales du cycle au
café de dominique romain gad et
s'apprête à ouvrir un nouveau restaurant
la spécialité des poissons de loire
rarement cuisiner comme le silure le
mulet et les envies jour la moitié de sa
clientèle est amené par la loire à vélo
[Musique]
je suis pêcheur professionnel en loire
il ya une partie de ma pêche que je
transforme
henriette en poissons fumés en plats
préparés et puis une autre partie que je
vends dans mon restaurant les gens
cherchent des choses
local typiques du terroir donc ils
viennent assez facilement ici
[Musique]
la loi à vélo est une aubaine pour ces
petits villages à la création de la
véloroute en 2005
certains élus craignaient de voir
affluer des vagues de touristes dans
leur paisible territoire le maire de
savonnières a toujours cru en cette
aventure aujourd'hui c'est sa commune
aux bords du cher qui voit le plus de
cyclotouristes passé cent mille l'an
dernier on a une demande d'installation
commerces de bouche principalement est
là ou là nous en avoir la maison du
passeur on viendrait installer un
commerçant
qui fait des cafés des des repas expédié
tout ça il ya vraiment une demande parce
qu'on sent qu'il ya un attrait ce qu'on
ne veut pas nous par contre c'est qu'on
ne veut pas on veut que ce soient des
activités pérennes
certes avec des pics en été mais on veut
pas que ce soit ouvert seulement trois
mois de l'année est fermé le reste de
l'année
karine et son mari sont achetés cette
boulangerie à savonnières il ya sept ans
l'unité genre et mentale chronique à
prouver ils se sont adaptés à la
clientèle à vélo pour mieux les
accueillir ils ont engagé une personne
de plus en fabrication
un apprenti et une vendeuse à mi temps
et l'argent sont les horaires en période
estivale ont fait journée continue et
donc ça c'est la quatrième année
consécutive pour le fait voilà ça permet
de bad est là présent pour les cyclistes
à toute heure de la journée mais ils
mangent pas forcément un lit mais ça
peut être à 14 heures et ils ont besoin
de trouver des commerces ouverts sur
leur passage oui tu fais sandwich avec
sabrina s'il te plaît mais après tu
finiras tarte aux fraises bédard gearon
aussi la loire à vélo et ça nous apporte
quelque chose de
de plus les sandwichs surtout en salle
et on va doubler voire tripler le volume
merci à tous que ihealth aller mais
aussi tout ce qui est sucré la
pâtisserie beaucoup le flanc le flanc
c'est facile à manger pour le cycliste
ils s'arrêtent pas les touristes à vélo
dépensent en moyenne 80 euros par jour
pour manger bien sûr mais aussi pour se
loger un beau pays de france au revoir
[Musique]
leur hébergement favori le camping près
d'un cyclotouriste sur deux y séjournent
[Musique]
dans ce camping très nature de cheverny
la clientèle à vélo à son espace
ce couple de hollandais vient y passer
une nuit
oui
ce gigote hors antenne for you need
hauteur as you can use en saut de
communes kitchen un ebook sa de fried
chicken cook audi space pour 15 euros
ils peuvent dormir dans un vrai lit ou
dans une tente déjà installés et se
faire à dîner dans la petite cuisine
[Musique]
on
c'est la première fois que nous voyons
ça d'habitude nous allons dans des
campings où nous devons planter notre
propre tente tout installer ici c'est
une super option nous dépensons entre 50
et 60 euros par jour surtout pour la
nourriture
le prix du camping est à peu près
toujours le même il nous reste de
l'argent pour dîners dans des
restaurants plus luxueux en termes
d'investissements ces trois unités nous
auront coûté 2000 2500 euros
d'investissement pour les produits
spécifiques donc aidé par la région pour
nous soutenir les gens vont donner et se
déplacent pas avec le matériel des
fouilles sont fatigués de ne pas faire
la cuisine et tout ça derrière on a les
services pour leur proposer et la met à
disposition tout cela donc au bout du
compte un lot randonneurs économiquement
et un développement important
[Musique]
pour choisir leur hébergement les
cyclistes sont guidés par ce logo la
marque loire à vélo
les professionnels du tourisme peuvent y
prétendre s'il se situe à moins de 5 km
d'un itinéraire officielle celle ci
propose des services spécifiques pour
les cyclotouristes
alors effectivement nos clients la loire
à vélo ont régulièrement besoin de laver
leurs affaires donc nous leur proposons
effectivement une dans notre landry
notre laverie et bien à la fois de laver
leurs affaires et desséchées la plupart
des randonneurs ne reste qu'une nuit
mais les hébergeurs ne pense plus long
terme de nuitées
il voit investissement à long terme la
loire à vélo un intérêt s'est calé
attractive pour des séjours de courte
durée mais elle permet aussi de faire
découvrir et c'est le boulot de tous les
prestataires de tourisme de faire
découvrir la région
l'attractivité et toutes les activités
qui peuvent exister pour des séjours
beaucoup plus long et s'ils sont bien
reçues même une nuit il n'oublie jamais
être aux petits soins des cyclotouristes
pour qu'il revienne c'est ce pourquoi a
été engagée cette jeune tourangelle
bonjour vient chercher les bagages de la
famille germany pendant que vous faites
votre randonnée à vélo
amélie s'occupe de transférer vos
bagages d'un lieu d'hébergement à
l'autre un sac et de sacs à dos donc ça
nous fait neuf donc ça fait je l'aimais
là
[Musique]
un master de sciences humaines en poche
elle est restée six mois au chômage
avant de décrocher ce cdd pour l'été
[Musique]
ça va me donner peut-être des idées
aussi pour pour la suite pourquoi pas un
jour développer aussi mon entreprise
dont pourquoi pas de la livraison
d'autres choses je sais pas voilà mais
ça sert de gagne-pain agréable et de bon
tremplin
ce tremplin a été créée par ses deux
frères tourangeaux en 2013 deux valises
leur entreprise emploie une dizaine de
saisonniers d'avril à octobre génère
sont cinquante mille euros de chiffre
d'affaires
un chiffre qui augmente de 20% chaque
année grâce un bon plan comme le sait
montrer aux gens expliqué aux gens
intéressés qu'ils savent que ce service
existe bien que c'est abordable parce
que le réflexe élire non ça c'est pas
pour moi c'est forcément un service très
cher et quand on propose de porter un
balayage sur une étape à 13 euros
c'est à la portée de toutes les bourses
tous les secteurs du tourisme semble
bénéficier de succès de la loire à vélo
reste le tourisme qui est un peu à la
traîne
c'est beaucoup de temps à consacrer pour
la dégustation la vente
les livraisons etc parce que les
cyclistes ne peuvent pas forcément
repartir avec leurs cartons de vin sur
le porte bagages
donc c'était beaucoup de temps à y
consacrer et je pense que beaucoup de
domaines pour ne pouvait pas ou ne
voulaient pas embaucher quelqu'un
exclusivement pour cette tâche
on se dit qu'il faut y aller parce
qu'effectivement ces gens là sont très
demandeur on s'est rendu compte aussi
que sur le trajet de la loire à vélo
s'en sortir j'irai de lax ya pas il n'ya
pas multitude de bons endroits où on
peut déguster le vin et nous sommes donc
on a la chance donc de voir l'itinéraire
qui traverse le vignoble entièrement et
qui passe devant notre cave
donc effectivement nous aurons les
projets de développement qui vont dans
ce sens du coup une personne va être
engagé à plein temps pour accueillir les
cyclotouristes un emploi de plus et un
marché grand ouvert pour les
viticulteurs marché qui intéresse les
maisons des vins à cheverny entre la
piste cyclable et le château
l'emplacement est stratégique pour
attirer les cyclistes
on vient de déguster ils repartent soit
avec une ou deux bouteilles de suite
soit ils reviennent plus tard avec la
voiture chercher quelques caisses pour
vous c'est une bonne clientèle à voir
avec ça vous amène du monde avec
constaté oui oh oui forcément oui on a
on a beaucoup de cyclistes hoc
on les reconnaît tous ceux qui sont
équipés de leurs casques et des
cyclistes dans les jardins des châteaux
dans les musées et dans les petits
villages la loire à vélo attire de
nouveaux touristes depuis plus de dix
ans cette manne financière
la région compte bien la faire
fructifier son dernier investissement 25
millions d'euros dans ces rames de
trains modulable pour encourager les
franciliens à venir
[Musique]
et l'environnement dans tout ça les
professionnels du tourisme ont tout
intérêt à le préserver
c'est l'authenticité de ces sites
naturels que les cyclotouristes viennent
chercher